has encompassed culture and media and
politics and what you're allowed to say
and and universities and all that so it
makes more sense to focus on that but
little sliver of it that's on the right
yeah it's shitty it's horrible you
should not look at your skin color as
some great thing that makes you better
or but it's not a right thing is racism
always a right thing like though racists
right no I think the left is far more
racist than the right at the moment yeah
why do you think that because identity
politics is based in racism you happen
to be white I know nothing about you by
the color of your skin I know about Joe
Rogan because I watched the show I
listen to the show we've done this
several times and we can further ours
that we're gonna sit here now we can
dive as deep into any issue and that's
the only way that I can sensibly judge
you but the idea that you will look at
people that you would look at a black
person a black person would be sitting
there or a Muslim person would be
sitting there or transfers and sitting
there and you'd go
I have even inkling of what you think
because of that immutable characteristic
that is actual racism that is prejudging
right judging first before you know
somebody so I have a much bigger issue
with that because that has infected
everything in American society right now
the identity politics of the right that
this should be a white ethno state or
something like that but is that not
that's not really the identity politics
of the right well I don't think the left
is necessarily that way either I mean I
think the identity politics there's a
real issue right with people that only
identify with other women women that
only identify with women and don't care
about men there's a real issue with
people that are only American they don't
care about the rest of the world it's
like there's all these weird groups but
I think we run into problems when we
start saying oh it's the left it's doing
this it's the right that's doing this I
think it's just tribal it's just this
weird thing that human beings tend to
gravitate towards tribes for sure and
look we can we can I talk about things
usually from a little more of a
political lens than I think you do so
yes of course ultimately it is tribalism
however you want to parse that tribalism
right
so yes the let and I say this all time
but the left-right thing doesn't make
that much sense anymore you're either
basically your
basically for freedom you're for the
individual to live freely however they
see fit or you believe that the
government should engineer things and
that there should be central planning so
that people I think that's always shitty
thinking I think people that say that
the government should engineer things
they're just looking for a solution and
then they think the government should
handle it well yeah but I think I think
we should pay more taxes or is that
gonna go it's gonna go to the government
and what's your no no no me you're
thinking I mean there's like they're
having shitty thinking it's like this
idea that the government's gonna fix it
the government's filled with people like
we don't have our own individual
solution so we don't have a solution as
human just as human beings objective
human beings looking at problems why
would we ever think that elected
officials these these people that are
for the most part full of yeah like
they're just trying to say whatever they
can say that's gonna appease both the
special interest groups and the
lobbyists and the people that are
helping them get into place the people
they're going to vote for them and you
know and then just sort of like skirt
around all the other issues that are
controversial to the point where they
can get into office let's try name 3
politicians that you really like I don't
know Johnson who was like who I liked
him too and I voted for him but he was
the worst possible Libertarian candidate
you know who's the best Libertarian
candidate
I mean Rand Paul should be if he really
had the balls to be what he is got to
learn how to stuff a takedown yeah he's
got a lot guys coming at she gonna brawl
you could do you could do two hours with
him and he'd be a lot better in a lot of
ways but he should be the guy but he
doesn't have the balls to do it because
he wants to maintain being a Republican
senator in Kentucky and he's not gonna
do it if he has to leave the party but
if but I've seen a major shift I think
in Republicans or at least conservatives
or generally people on the right
whatever you want to call that thing
there is a massive libertarian streak
that is alive in them right now which is
why most of the people that I like these
days that I get along with that I think
are fair and decent and honest are
pretty much libertarian define the
return so libertarian so libertarian in
classical liberal is what I get more
than
because I say I'm a classical liberal
which basically means you believe in the
individual the sovereignty of the
individual is the simple most important
thing it is your life it is your duty to
do what you see fit the government is
supposed to do pretty much nothing other
than protect your life so it's supposed
to have an army and police and stuff
like that and then really just lays a
fare economics and that and then the
difference between classical liberal and
libertarian is how far do you want to go
with the government so I think there is
some utility for the state but the more
I do this the more I have these
conversations and I talked to Anne Capps
and real libertarians and all that I
find it hard to defend the state at
almost any level at this point but I do
think that because I don't want to live
in Mad Max fury road just yet although
we may be heading there I still will
defend the state at some level but I
would say everything should be local we
have an incredible experiment here with
50 states if your state tax is too high
move go somewhere else if your state
doesn't have good education you can go
somewhere else if you don't like the
weather somewhere but the second we make
everything federal and this is what it's
not just the left this is what people
who were using lazy thinking that you
referred to they think we should just
have one law that we should all live
exactly the same no matter where we are
geographically no matter what our
religion or what however we set our set
of uses that is a nightmare that is a
nightmare for a totalitarian state
because if if the federal government if
one government controls everything guess
what if you don't like it you got to
leave the country you know go to Mexico
go to Canada you probably won't like it
really referring to it because in terms
of like you want set of laws well
because you want states rights you
should care about his state right so for
example we live in California we are
taxed out the wazoo I bought a
house last year it's my first time at 41
years old that I own property in America
I made it I own property I don't have to
tell you about my property taxes they're
insane they're very on their absurdly
absurdly high that's the price you pay
for living in a spot where everybody
wants to live ya know but that's it
that's the beauty right so like there's
a trade-off there now I could move to
Texas and the property taxes would be
way low and maybe because they don't tax
as much the schools aren't as good or a
series of other things but that's the
beauty of the foot vote you can go this
is an
this thing in America against that of
anyone that wants to keep giving more
power to the federal government which is
pretty much everybody these days pretty
much everybody in mainstream certainly
all of the Democrats all of you know the
the the mainstream set of Democrats and
the Bernie and the progressive crew they
would love for the federal government to
control everything and that is an
absolute nightmare but when I say
control everything like how so they want
to control all economics Department of
Education can figure out all the
environmental regulations all of those
things I would kickback everything to
the states let the state's decide and if
you don't like it get goin I mean that's
that's a beautiful thing if you if you
really care about marijuana and you live
in Alabama right now and it's not legal
guess what go to Colorado go to
California I mean that that's that's how
you'll influence things because you can
move your family your value whatever you
bring to your community in your life I
mean think about it right now if
California just kept taxing higher and
higher and kept screwing up a lot of
this the ton that's going wrong in the
state eventually Joe Rogan might be like
you know I just built this freaking
kick-ass new studio here I'm now paying
hundreds of thousands of dollars in
taxes and all this stuff you might want
to try it somewhere else where they're
gonna tax you less but that's the beauty
of the thing you don't have to leave the
country so the federal government should
pretty much do nothing it should make
sure we're not warring with each other
that the states aren't warring that's
about and then protect the borders
beyond that it doesn't have to do a lot
leave it to the States